documenting your business mistakes may
be the most important thing you do in
your entire business career to make more
money after I lost everything for the
second time in my career that experience
was so painful that I was like I can't
keep doing this I can't keep repeating
these same mistakes so I was like I have
to find a way that I can learn from this
and so within the next three months I
started my podcast and the intention
behind that podcast was that I would
learn to document the things that I was
doing and what I was thinking about and
the problems that I was suffering from
at that time and I always thought the
concept of having like a Jeff basos Vlog
with Once once a week he was like this
is what we're dealing with at Amazon
this is what we're dealing with Amazon
all the way to his current state would
have been so valuable and I always had
the belief that I would get to that
level eventually and so you know
delusional or not so I thought why not
start now and so I started documenting
my mistakes and my successes and an
interesting thing happened from that
point until now I haven't lost
everything again and we've built know
$100 million plus net worth arguably a
lot more than that but just for the sake
of this video um in that next seven or
so years and so I've been in business
for 13 but I lost everything about the
halfway point twice and so making sure
that I learned the right lessons from my
mistakes has been I think one of the
largest contributing factors to me being
able to move forward at such a fast rate
whether you document it through video or
you document it through podcast or you
document through written I don't think
matters I've actually done both and so I
started with just podcast but the ideas
for that podcast came from an email
thread that I had to myself and so every
year I would start a new email thread
called lessons and failures and then and
then the year and it would be hundreds
of emails long to myself and it would
just be little little tidbits little one
phrase two phrase of like oh yeah I had
this interview with this girl she did
this thing I think that's awesome and
then six months later when I find out
that person's stealing I'm like oh that
thing that I thought was good is
actually not good so I'd have these kind
of like continuous open looped stories
that I'd be telling about what I think
will happen versus what actually would
happen and then it'll allow me to have
much more crystallized decision-making
power in the future because I was like
wait a second I've seen this one before
and I know how this one goes and so that
happened more and more times so you
think about like if entrepreneurship
were a video game you have levels so if
you ever picked up an old video game and
then you like beat it really quickly to
the levels you remember and then you get
to like the level you don't know and
then it's like really slow again and
it's I think entrepreneurship is a lot
the same way is cuz you were like oh I
know where that pothole is oh I know I
can go get the extra ammo there I know
how to get this I know what this
director of sales should look like I
know what a director of marketing should
look like oh I've never run Facebook ads
before slow and then you just die die
die die and you respawn over and then
finally you get through and then the
next time you beat all six levels and
then you also beat the Facebook level
and you're like all right well now we're
going to run YouTube ads and you're like
die die die and so I see
entrepreneurship a lot of the same way
but if there's so many things that are
happening every day in business that if
you don't have a way to crystallize the
knowledge to document what you've done
it's like you don't develop this
repertoire at least for me not as easily
because the Nuance of what I remember it
fades right I don't remember like what
was the big breakthrough here I'm like I
just know that it worked but I want to
know why it worked so that when a new
situation comes up I can know how to
increase the likelihood that it happens
again and so nowadays I publicly do this
stuff through shorts and Longs and
tweets but fundamentally the thing that
got me into doing it in the early days
was the side benefit that people would
watch it but the primary benefit that
future me would be able to reference
back to this thing and know where I was
at that time what I was struggling with
what beliefs I had and that was probably
the one those was most interesting was
hey if there was a period of time where
I was crushing it how was I seeing the
world and is it different than now so
it's almost like having a time machine
so it's like okay if all of a sudden I
get into like a losing streak I'm going
to go back to when I was winning and I'm
going to watch some of the stuff that I
was doing then so I can keep it top of
mind like oh what am I what's different
between these two things but if I don't
have that to reference then I just have
to go off memory but my memory in the
current state is being jaded by my
current situation and so I want to be
able to have a source I can go back to
truth and truth just being things that
are documented and so I see this as a
really huge problem for a lot of small
business owners or really just business
owners in general is that they make a
mistake but they learn the wrong lesson
from it and so Dr Burgman talked about
this where he said it's worse to to be
successful and not know why than to have
failed and know why correctly and it's
me paraphrasing but that struck me when
I heard that for the first time and I
think the reason it struck me was that
it took me years to figure out why gym
launch was actually so successful in the
beginning now obviously for me I was
like I'm 27 years old took home $17
million in income my first year that's
not Revenue that was profit you know in
my first 12 calendar months of the
business like I'm so great um but we are
so quick to attribute failure to an
outside circumstance but we don't
attribute success to an outside
circumstance and I had number of things
that were going well for me at that time
and so it's like I had Facebook ads that
were super cheap which made the stuff
that our gyms were using super cheap and
super profitable for me to acquire
customers as gym owners was also super
cheap and super profitable and so I had
these things that were working you know
I was like I'm just such a good marketer
but it wasn't that right I mean because
years later when that Arbitrage
disappeared right it's like is the same
is the same thing happening right so
what happened is the gym launch had to
evolve from an Arbitrage business to one
that went off of execution and me
basically realizing this like what why
is why are why is it not printing the
way it was before it's like oh it's
because the context has changed and so I
became a much better entrepreneur
despite the fact that the net income
went down and so learning from that is
both humbling but also the only thing
that you can do to get better and if we
see ourselves as the asset that we're
ultimately building throughout our lives
which we eventually just cash in at the
the end and die anyways then making sure
that I'm getting the right thing the
right lesson from the scar is arguably
the most important thing that you can
have to move faster cuz when you watch
that person Play that video game again
when they know the game it's not like
they're moving super fast they just
don't make the wrong turn they go
directly for the ammo they go directly
you know they avoid the poth the pothole
they avoid the bads too um they they
they hit the dragon right at The Sweet
Spot cuz they know where it is cuz they
died 20 other times hitting the wrong
part of the Dragon that's not the sweet
The Sweet Spot um and so they just it's
more efficient movement they have less
wasted moves and so I see that the same
way as entrepreneurship it's not like
the businesses that I have are so much
bigger than the ones that I had before
and they grow so much faster because I
know how to go through their first early
levels really quickly because of what
I've documented before here's what it
looks like when it's wrong so I'll talk
to you know a small business owner and
say Hey you know I hired a salesperson
and then it they didn't work out and I'm
like cool so what' you learn from that
this is always one of my favorite
questions like what' you learn from that
and so I asked this to myself like what'
you learn from that um and so with this
particular individual he say like well
no one can sell like I can sell I'll be
like well I think you might have learned
the wrong lesson from the mistake and
like the only thing worse than wrong
like than having the mistake is learning
the wrong lesson from the mistake
because then you're bound to repeat it
again and so a fool never learns from
their mistakes a dumb person learns from
their mistakes eventually a smart person
learn learns one lesson from a mistake a
very smart person learns multiple
lessons from a mistake a wise man learns
from the mistake of others the wisest
man learns from their successes too and
so the idea is if we think about that as
a Continuum of how we can move more
efficiently through life and get more
for every move it's making sure that
we're like that person playing the video
game that when we go back through we
know what potholes to avoid cuz imagine
if you played the game and you're like
oh I killed this guy because I hit him
in the sweet spot and you thought The
Sweet Spot was here but the real thing
was that you had a certain arrow that
you picked up earlier in the game and
when you play the game again you don't
think it's about the arrow you think
it's about the spot and so then you hit
the spot again it doesn't work it's
because you attributed the success to
the wrong
lesson and so I actually see this happen
a lot I think it's one of the most
common mistakes that happens in
entrepreneurship is that people just
extrapolate their current view of the
world over the mistake but fundamentally
the people who are better at business
see business more clearly they can
recognize the mistake more easily and
they're correct because they have a high
predictive power meaning if they want
this thing to happen again they can
predict that it will or what it would
take to make the dragon die because they
had the right thing which is it's
actually not the spot or the arrow it's
both you're like ah right and only
somebody who's lived through both of
those experiences well the next time
they came with the arrows that were
right they hit in a different spot it
didn't work either so you're like oh
it's the combination of things and often
times it's not one thing it's two or
three things that have to happen at the
same time for the outcome to occur and
so like when I started Allen my third
company that I was CEO of at the same
time you can already tell me smiling
because of the obvious mistake that I
was making um Allen was a hard business
it was a I'd never been in software
before i' never developed software
before I'd never had Engineers before
product design ux I didn't know any of
this stuff I was like I just know that
this is I knew the problem and I knew i
product Market fit because I knew
exactly what needed to get built and I
knew I had a whole audience that I could
sell to um but here's all the lessons
that I learned from that hey and if
you're in the early part of your
business career avoiding mistakes is one
of the most important things you can do
in order to move faster not to say that
you're not going to make them you're
going to make a ton of them but ideally
you want to make ones that you can that
you can't avoid rather than the mistakes
you can avoid and uh for people just
getting started in business I run
something called the school games uh on
school.com um for SL games and in there
I take calls I help people build their
first business on the platform uh and
you can start for free all right so if
that's at all interesting you can go
school.com games one is software is hard
second that you don't want to get into a
features war with competitors like
competitors in software that can easily
copy any features you have and so you
want to have other things about your
business that give you more of a moat
that protects you from just a race to
the bottom and a features War um the
main the probably the biggest lesson I
learned from it was yet again another
lashing from the woman in the red dress
um the reason I'm so vehemo about the
wom in the red dress is that of all the
mistakes that I've had to learn she has
been the sneakiest and the most devious
of them and the one that I've had to
learn the same lesson over and over and
over again um and I would say I IID say
to a certain degree I'm ashamed of that
of how many times I've had to learn not
to pursue the win the red dress and it's
like because every time you know now
she's black now she's Asian now she's
white and now she's tall now she's short
sometimes she's wearing a short dress
sometimes it's not red it's it's maroon
sometimes it's you know faded mango for
the color but every time I'm like no no
no this time's different and you can
probably tell like if you have that
friend who dates the same girl over and
over again they're like no no this
girl's different you're like dude it's
the same thing it's it's like super pacy
work girl uh you know super tatted up
you know dad issues whatever right it's
like you'd run the same Playbook man
like this is obviously not work for you
obviously I also have no issues with
anybody who looks like that I'm just
saying as an example and the main lesson
that I learned from Allan was that it
was the only argument that Lea and I
have ever been in and it was actually a
business argument which I find hilarious
um and she just didn't think that we had
the bandwidth to do to bring on another
company and do it and I argued that she
needed to think bigger and that you know
we had to we had to take big swings and
all of that and I ended up just
steamrolling her and it was a Terri
decision for a number of reasons but one
of the biggest ones was that my operator
wasn't on board even if she wasn't my
wife the person who's going to be
running this thing wasn't on board with
it and was telling me shouting at me
quite literally that she she was so
spread thin with the current businesses
that take on something else would just
one of them would
suffer and so that's exactly what
happened right and so it had nothing to
do and like maybe if I had only done
that then we would have grown it you
know and been a gazillion dollar thing
there's nothing wrong with the concept
behind the business and often times for
everybody there's often not something
fundamentally wrong with the concept
behind the business like you have some
service or some problem that you solve
for some specific customer it's just all
the other stuff right and being able to
recognize oh that is not what a sales
director looks like but until you hire
that person have them you know spend six
months wasting leads on them and then
having them fail and then hire another
sales director and again six months of
not growth because they're not closing
the way they need to and then on the
third when you finally find it you're
like oh this is what a sales director
looks like this is what a sales director
does and then because guess what happens
is that from that point going on in your
life you know how to beat that level and
so you quickly put the right sales
director in in your second company your
third company or whatever it is or a new
division in the company because you know
what it looks like when it's right and
so I think making sure that it's like
okay I know how to kill the dragon
because the sales director can't just be
charismatic they also have to have
systems things and they have to do both
of them and they have to care about
people or whatever and so it's not
usually one or two things it's usually a
handful and that's what makes business
complex and so trying to remember
all of these little details is so hard
that it became so important for me to
document those things and you get the
double benefit when you document that
you make content about it and so you can
both build your personal brand if you're
into that and get the benefit of
documenting the lessons which is the
real benefit as the entrepreneur and I
find it interesting because a lot of uh
people a lot of business owners who make
content ask me how do I come up with
content ideas and I always found that
such a silly question because I I always
have so many things to talk about and I
think it's because the the easiest thing
to talk about is the news you just look
at what's going on and you make
commentary on it which is why a lot of
channels or people over time just
divulge into just news reporters with
commentary but I don't think that's the
right way to do it I prefer to talk
about my news because life is always
happening and so I also have problems
and so unless you have no problems in
life which I don't think anybody
watching this has no problems in life
you talk about the problems that you're
dealing with right now and how you're
approaching them and you also just do it
in in AAR like if you if you don't feel
like being vulnerable fine because there
sometimes there's things in business
that you can't you know if you have a
you know employee sh I'm dealing with
Daniel who's behind the camera right now
and I'm like I got this problem with
this videographer you know what I mean
then like I probably can't talk about it
right now right but if I could talk
about it three like literally if we
solve something and then three months
later I say hey Dan and I we're having
this beef but we figured this thing out
it's totally cool right and so we just
talk about you talk about a little bit
in rear and that way you're not risking
anything client relationships whatever
but you just talk about your news rather
than the news you'll always have source
of content and it'll allow you to
document your business mistakes and
successes so that you learn the right
lessons and so let me tell you how
powerful this is so I had I had dinner
years ago with an entrepreneur uh who
had exited a company that was an
e-commerce company and he had made the
majority of their sales on Amazon this
is the early days of Amazon uh when like
you could pretty much just like list a
product and it would just grow because
like there was reviews hacking and
there's all sorts of stuff and so we had
dinner with this entrepreneur and I
remember him saying this he said isn't
it crazy that you could never have a
business successful ever again like this
could be the most successful business
you ever have and it was because he
attributed everything that he had in his
life to the luck of things working out
you know in Tandem and the reality was
that for him that was true and for us it
was also true but we had crystallized
the knowledge because we had wanted to
study what made us successful and so
since that point he has not had a
business that was more successful than
that first one that he had we have had
everyone since be more successful than
the first one that we had and the
difference was did you document the
lessons are you just playing a video
game that's the same game but you're
acting like a new character like you've
never played it before because you never
wrote down what you were supposed to do
when you got to the first boss or the
first pothole and I think it's just as
important like I said to study your
successes and so like our supplement
launch for Prestige Labs was probably
the most successful launch in terms of
like cleanliness like no problems of
anything we've ever done and the
difference between that launch and some
of the other ones was that I had my
operator on board the team had been
completely trained up we had an alpha
phase we had a beta phase we worked
through all the Kinks in the process I
let them set the date for when the
launch was going to be we were staffed
up we were trained we had inventory we
had everything we had all the little
holes figured out and the first month we
did $1.7 million in recurring Revenue
recurring crazy for supplements and so
the crazy thing about that
was I had learned from the mistakes that
I've done before and so I was like how
can I not make those and also this
worked out well how do I make sure that
I repeat successful actions how do I
make sure that I check every one of
these boxes the next time because
nothing feels like success which is one
of Lea's favorite sayings she's like
well we have to remember that it took us
a year to do this and so if we want to
do another thing we can't think oh we
just crushed that we can Crush another
one she's like no the point is that it
took us a long time and a lot of work
and a lot of buying and a lot of
training a lot of resources for an
extended period of time to make this big
thing work right the first time and so
when we do something else we have to
understand that's the price that we have
to be willing to pay and having that
context you think wow okay I know to
beat the next level it's going to take
me two hours but Mom wants to go to the
grocery store so I probably shouldn't
start that level right now because I'm
not going to be able to finish it and
so having the context of what kind of
resources am I going to have to put to
towards this gives you a more realistic
view of how many things you can actually
take on and do well and I think that big
picture that has probably been one of my
biggest meta lessons is that once I
learn how long it takes me to do
something well I learned how few things
I can actually do which means that I
have to say no to just about everything
even if and Steve Jobs was was famous
for asking his his executive team this
he said what have you said no to lately
because he didn't want people to just
say they're focused the focus is
everything you turn away from he said
it's not just turning away from bad
ideas it has to be an idea that you in
your bones desperately want to do and
still choose not to because you said you
were going to stay focused on the one
thing that mattered most and that has
probably been one of the hardest lessons
it's the inverse of the woman in the red
dress for me because there's I've just I
there's so many things in like the
business world that I want to do I want
to try but knowing how much work it
takes to make one thing work very well
and just take a very long time to learn
this
um is that you just can't do many you
have to learn how to say no and once you
do start the game with all the lessons
you zoom past all the levels and you get
to the hard part which I call the Virgin
Territory right now it's how do I hire a
CFO how do I do a business transaction
how do I take on debt in a way that's
responsible how do I scale to a new
acquisition Channel how do I go from
five salese to 50 salese like what is
that process what does a career path
look like for a salesperson what does
career path look like for customer
success like is this is this customer
support or customer success like like
where do I find a good IT director who
can actually integrate all of our
systems together but what's interesting
that I've always thought about this is
that like we were able to grow so
quickly in gym launch sure we had the
Arbitrage of the Facebook stuff that was
happening but I also came into it having
run six locations with 30 plus employees
and you know eight eight sales guys and
so I was used to 30 50 sometimes 100
sales a day on my team and and so if I
went to as soon as we started gym launch
I immediately went up to what my level
of incompetence was or my level of Max
competence right equal opposite is I
knew what it was like to spend $1,000 a
day I knew what it was like to spend
$3,000 a day I knew what it was like to
uh have eight sales guys taking calls
all day long and so I could quickly
scale to that which is why we went from
basically nothing to 26 million that
next year because I was used to that
level of activity we had more zeros on
the price tag but everything else was
the same and one of the greatest Parts
about documenting things publicly is
that you now become accountable to the
lessons you claim you learned and so I
think that if you think about the
benefits of documenting business
mistakes and business successes publicly
is there's three things one is you make
it for you and so it will help you learn
the lesson better and telling the story
makes it stick if you just try and
remember a lesson it doesn't apply it's
kind of like um Elon Musk had this clip
that I I sent on a whole team but he
talks about how education is all wrong
they have a course on a wrench and they
have a course on a screwdriver he said
they shouldn't teach that way because
you don't have context your brain can't
remember it but you said hey let's take
apart this engine now everyone looks at
the engine he says oh I guess we'll
probably need a wrench but now the
wrench has contextualized the problem
that help solve right and so when we
tell the stories it helps contextualize
the problem that we're solving at the
time so that when a problem's similar to
that when a girl with a red dress comes
up and she's got short hair you're like
okay I have one of you guys before I had
long hair and the dress was you know
shorter but I think you're related right
and so you have the first benefit which
is that you crystallize the lesson the
second is that you're accountable to
that lesson because there's people who
are watching it who are like hey I
thought you said that you didn't want to
do a lot of these things you can't be
CEO of multiple things right right and
so it holds you accountable to that and
then the third benefit is that you
actually make money from it because
people will identify with your values
and your beliefs and say hey I'd like to
do business with you that if you see
that as gravy then you won't lose
because you never did it for them to
begin with so instead of giving a non-
answer to like what's the one thing that
you think you attribute a lot of your
success to I actually do have some
answers one is the time blocking thing
that I that I I made a video about the
other day which is like my productivity
system or something some YouTube
headline um but basically the maker
manager time understanding the
difference between those things but the
second is that okay if I can maximize my
maker manager time then I maximize the
raw unit but now I want to get the most
for that time and I think this what I'm
talking about today with crystallizing
those lessons has been probably the
second most valuable thing that I've
done in my career so it's I need to make
time so I can do the work that matters
most and then I need to document the
mistakes that I made so that when I do
that work that matters most I'm actually
working on on the work that matters most
and so using the video game analogy it's
like if Allen were a video game and I'm
trying to win at that game then I've got
a co-op player my wife and business
partner who doesn't want to play the the
game it becomes very hard to win when
you're doing Co-op and one player
doesn't want to play or wants to win at
a different game right and so there are
a lot of lessons not just that one that
I learned from from Allen as a company
and I've learned lessons from every
company I've had but not being able to
look back because it was so long ago
would increase the likelihood that I am
forced to replay that level again
because I wouldn't remember why I failed
so if you had to apply the woman of the
red dress to a video game scenario iio
it would really be like trying to play
two video games at the same time and win
it both like just think about how crazy
it is like there's two ways you can
think about it one is that you literally
try and play both games at the same time
which obviously no one's going to win
what's crazy that entrepreneurs do this
all the time the second scenario might
be a little bit more realistic is that
you're alternating between games it's
like one day you play this game one day
you play that game one day you play this
game but if you you'll notice that when
you do that you're kind of like Rusty
you kind of like got to like get
yourself right back up to speed like
your hands got to like you got to learn
the key not like you got you're just
rusty right you got to get read up or
sped up now do that with three games and
you're playing one game you know ABC ABC
well imagine the guy who's just playing
on a that guy's your competitor he's
going to not be three times better than
you he's probably going to be like six
or nine times better than you because
not only is he spending three more 3x
the time on the actual game as you but
he also doesn't have the cost of change
and the cost of getting caught up to
speed every single time and so he might
be six or nine times ahead and you're
like how is this guy beating me it's
like cuz he's not doing anything else
and so I like to think like how would I
play this game if I had to win like
there was no option for failing well I
definitely wouldn't have any I wouldn't
be playing any other games I definitely
would Orient my entire life around the
video game I would definitely make sure
that like food was brought to me you
know you know drinks were brought to me
uh I'm you know sleeping optimally I've
got everything that I need my lighting
all that stuff would be optimized so
that I could just play this game and the
people who make the most money in
business call it the game the reason the
show is called the game is because I
think everyone is in the game it's just
that a lot of people don't know
it and so as soon as you realize that
you are playing a video game with money
in business then all the same rules
apply and you want to have your Prima
officially official strategy guide next
to you of all the lessons that you've
learned along the way it's just that
this game has way more
than 10 keys on a keyboard and way more
players because everyone in the world is
playing and they're are no rules besides
not going to
jail and so you have a true open
world game with real
stakes and players that have been
playing for 60 years who are competing
against
you and so I just want to do everything
in my power are to make sure that I
increase the likelihood that I can win
so if you aren't documenting your
successes start if you aren't
documenting your failures start you can
also not doesn't really matter when I
didn't do it I made a lot less money
when I started doing I started making a
lot more money and so I would say do it
whatever way you can if it's just
Twitter and tweeting it or if it's an
email chain yourself or it's a audio
messages yourself or just when you're
driving whatever version of that it is
as long as you make you the main
audience then you won't worry about the
reviews you won't worry about the
performance you'll just get get better
at it and I think that honestly having
done 700 and something solo podcasts up
to this point I've gotten better at
talking just because I was forced to if
you listen to my early podcast compared
to now I'm more articulate how did that
happen because I did it a load of times
and so the same thing will happen to you
and you'll actually get practice on
making content on presenting to your
staff on presenting to your team on
presenting to customers by doing it
more so a question from the audience is
do you see Lila as your guide so I think
there's like guide with a capital G and
then guide with a little G so guide with
a capital would be the assumption that
like Lila is my guide in life and the
answer would be no I would say that
we're Partners we do things these things
together but within the context of the
story in that instance yeah she came in
with the insight and that's what changed
the character got me over the obstacle
and got me to the next thing and I think
we both played that role for one another
um throughout our careers and having
somebody like that the hard part is just
finding somebody who actually wants you
to win it's just it's so rare everybody
has their own agenda and it's it's how
you can help them win um and so I mean
that's why I think at least you know
husbands and wives have the most L
incentives and so it it helps that when
they're selfish for themselves like you
can believe like sometimes they're wrong
but at least their intentions correct
and I think what's really cool about
documenting your mistakes and the
lessons from them is that we give such
great advice to other people and yet we
don't follow it for ourselves and so
when you actually write down the advice
that you want to give to yourself it
kind of stares back at you and you're
like man and one of the most powerful
frames that I've had in my life in terms
of like navigating difficult situations
is if I were coaching myself if I were
mentoring myself if I were my own guide
what would I tell me because the
beautiful thing is that you always have
complete context with the situation
because you're in it so you don't need
to tell somebody to try and get them up
to speed you are up to speed but most
people if I said Hey how do I lose
weight be like hey stop eating and
move more right but then when it's when
it's you you're like well I have all
these other things I have all these
emotional charges around all this crap
right but if we listen to our own advice
most of the time we don't like
information we lack execution so the
question is do I get just as much value
from my Solomon sessions is basically
when I talk to my future self which
sounds really sketchy but basically just
have a chat message thread with what I
imagine to be my 80- old version of
myself who's already accomplished
everything that I want to accomplish has
all the lessons learned and can reflect
back on my present situation versus what
I've learned from my past self and I
think that I've learned lessons from
both um and I think time travel is one
of the most useful frames for
crystallizing lessons and getting
insight into situations where you're
like I just don't know what to do
because it's like your present state in
your present condition with present
influences and things that are going on
in your head that are top of mind
doesn't but like future you definitely
had will ask a different question about
the scenario that often times just
erases the importance of it entirely so
the question was right now what big boss
are you dealing with I think that the
boss that I am dealing with right
now is actually just being patient and
so we
have all of the skills we brought from
all of the other businesses we've owned
and run and we're applying it to our
current business withth acquisition.
comom and I think it's much more of a
character trait test for me because the
model is working above projections when
I started it in
2021 and so I it's doing everything that
I hoped it would do and better which
Lila brings up all the time and I have a
huge desire to with like I
have a huge I'm a I'm a tinkerer I like
tinkering with things but most of the
time you don't need to Tinker when it is
working and so I think a lot of times in
business depending on what it is if it's
not like a lot of things are good enough
like if it's not the constraint of the
business then it's just a cost that you
force the business to incur by changing
anything like the cost of change is
guaranteed the upside from change isn't
and so if you have something that's
working well then whenever you change it
everything sets back because everyone
get has to get retrained on a new
process a new anything before it gets
back to even neutral let alone whether
it improves or not and so I think the
the big boss that I'm facing right now
is just a skill thing that I'm learning
which is just letting things grow
without getting in the way and if you
guys want know something very trippy
about this I didn't start having
compounding growth in my wealth until
after I started documenting my mistakes
and so until I lost lost everything the
second time I did not document my
mistakes I didn't document anything
after that point 90 days after I lost
everything 90 days three months is when
I made my first podcast and from that
point going forward I've spent more time
thinking about why did this work rather
than really anything else because if I
know why it worked then I can do it
again and so then I get to like conquer
that level and I just know that I can
always skip past it if I know the right
why and speaking of lessons and failures
I just made a video of 13 years of
business lessons that I've learned in 90
minutes go check it out enjoy